week to go in the regular season mets
close out their series against the
braves with a rubber game of three and
the mets are still alive in the
postseason chase they've got very little
margin for error though rick porisolo
gets the ball for the mets today hoping
to back up what david peterson did last
night the 2-2 on the way
is a fastball that is in there for a
call strike three
and he gets him with a breaking ball
porcello strikes out ozuna for the
second out
little tapper porcello off the mound the
bare hand play and on target to get
darno that retires the side you see
kyle's numbers three earned runs and
really had some bad luck his two starts
in september so far 56 percent fastballs
i think that's something we want to see
from him ball's two strikes
and strike three look at that pitch
that's
beautiful 95 inside corner the 2-2 pitch
is a swing and a miss that's an old jd
hammer right there swinging to miss
takes care of the mets duvall the former
cincinnati red
and he strikes out duvall with the
fastball away that's three strikeouts
through the first five batters for
porcello
a shot into right field is out of reach
of jimenez who is playing the rover spot
and ozzy obese has the game's first hit
and marcakus takes strike three called
and he knew it
he was looking for something else got
the two-seamer and that's the fourth
strikeout for porcello and pete alonso
is the batter
[Music]
a high strike in right takes care of
alonso three strikeouts for kyle right
austin riley leads often
and there's a strike called on the
outside corner and he gets riley for his
fifth strikeout first time through the
batting order ramos hitting 220 3-2 from
right
and ramos drills one toward the left
field corner headed toward the wall and
it hops one hop against the fence
and ramos will pull in at second base
with a two odd double so the first base
runner of the day for the mets and it's
ramos who needed to hit in the worst way
his sixth double of the year saw a full
count for brandon nimmo michael
conforto's next
and this one is in the air to center
acuna shielding his eyes says he's got
it and he does and a little longer than
we'd like but still the same result for
kyle wright three scoreless innings in
new york two out of nobody on for adam
duvall and he pops one up
nobody's gonna take this but dom i don't
think
nobody's calling him off he had him all
the way i said to ramos i i was owed one
five pitch inning for porcello no score
in the for it four oh struck out looking
his first time
swag and a miss big bender got conforto
to whiff for a second time kyle right
now with four strikeouts in the game
the 1-1
is again on the ground freeman ranges to
his right flips to right at the bag and
it's another three up three down inning
for
kyle right ozzy alves leads off in the
fifth inning and albie's takes strike
three called that two seamer that came
back on the inside corner and that is
strikeout number six for porcello which
matches his season high
and swanson pops it up
canoe has a beat on it and robbie puts
it away and that retires the side seven
in a row set down by porcello takes on
robinson canoe to lead off the bottom of
the fifth on a nice roll today as he got
known to swing and miss kyle wright has
his fifth strikeout matching his career
high set against the mets on august the
second two balls two strikes
and knuckle right back to the mound kyle
wright makes short work of jeff mcneal
and that is his 79th pitch through five
scoreless innings otto cunha jr top of
the order now for the braves
and that one's driven to right that ball
is high that ball is deep conforto
couldn't find it doesn't matter it's
over the yellow line for a home run a
rainbow homer a wall scraper for ronald
lacuna junior and he has given the
braves the first run of this game a one
out solo homer the other way two men
aboard one two to duvall
and he popped it up into shallow left
jimenez drifting out calling all the way
and that retires the sides
we'll start with ximena's one pitch on
the ground dansby's got it quick really
sandy gets his man for route number one
swinging a high fly ball right center
field back as acuna battling the sun on
the warning track makes the catch right
in front of the fence and it's a three
up three down for kyle wright as he
sails through the six there's nick
marcakis
foul tip for strike three and that's
strikeout number nine for porcello the
o2 swinging a missed strike three and
there is the tenth strikeout of the game
for rick porcello it's his first
double-digit strikeout game in over two
years
photo a nine-game hitting streak on the
line swinging a miss conforto's got the
hat trick it's 11 in a row retired and
kyle's got six strikeouts so a full
count for j.d davis who's walked five
times in the series
and he
checked his swing he walks again and the
tying run is on for the match just their
second base runner in the game no way is
snit going to let him stay in and risk
losing this game by making a mistake
with the man aboard but boy was kyle
wright outstanding will smith is on this
will be his 15th game that one on the
ground might be two one there on to
first it is a double play he does
preserve the lead and after seven kyle
wright's in line to win his second game
in a row on the second freeman over the
third acuna and with two down it'll be
darno's turn base hit here would be
enormous pitch on the way hit in the air
out towards right field that's in for a
base hit it rolls down the line into the
corner this easily scores freeman
anacuna a huge knock out of darneau he's
been coming through all year and it
gives the braves a three nothing lead
the bases are loaded the cunha's reached
base three times he scored twice
he drives that ball where it's pitched
it's headed for the right field corner
that's going to score all bees ncrt
comes around to score striking around is
swanson throw to the plate tag miss
dansby gets in with a belly flop and
ronald lacuna junior clears him with a
big hit a triple to right field there's
the 2-2 on the way
hit in the air to right field this one
might get back there towards the wall a
diving effort and michael conforto can't
come up with it that bounces off the
base of the wall the cunha will score
freddie freeman makes his way to third
base and marcelo zuna gives the braves a
seven nothing lead and the fate of the
mets rests in the hands of j.d davis
on the ground dansby's got it he'll
scoop and fire the braves are headed
home at long last with a seven nothing
shutout win against the new york mets
ronald lacuna junior drove in four runs
with a bases clearing double at the
moment the magic number for a third
consecutive eastern division title
stands at six as the mets hoping to make
a last stand for a divisional play lose
the series two out of three to the
braves on their home turf